bonsoir le journal de tv soixante dix
huit pour faire le tour de l'actualité
locale bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez
dans cette édition du mercredi 14
octobre voici les titres yvelines et
hauts de seine organise aujourd'hui leur
colloque de la protection de l'enfance
un rendez vous aux mureaux pour
réfléchir à l'amélioration de la prise
en charge des jeunes et parler des
dossiers à venir
le docteur benkemoun sera avec nous
d'ailleurs en plateau pour parler du
projet d'institut interdépartementale du
psycho traumatisme de l'enfant elle vise
à protéger les small bis et piétons
zombies rivés sur leur smartphone est
inattentif en milieu urbain et me envoie
des alertes à la proche des passages
cloutés à l'application est en phase de
test en ce moment à montigny le
bretonneux et puis jusqu'à la fin du
mois 7 octobre rose l'événement de
sensibilisation au cancer du sein samedi
dernier 160 personnes ont marché dans
les rues d'aubergenville en faveur de la
ligue contre le cancer
mais avant de développer ses titres
valérie pécresse ce matin au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
présidente de la région ile de france
est venu inaugurer un stade
d'entraînement de haute performance à
destination des futurs paix piété des
professionnels de la discipline
un concept novateur en europe le projet
est chiffré à 4,5 millions d'euros avec
60% de fonds publics saint quentin en
yvelines et la région font partie des
partenaires sur ce projet on écoute
valérie pécresse au micro de tv 78 ont
manqué d'infrastructures sportives par
rapport au reste de la france
donc on sait puissamment investi là
dessus davantage d'infrastructures de
proximité et des infrastructures
évidemment pas seulement à paris mais
dans toute l'ile-de-france petite grande
couronne de façon à ce que l'on mette
tous le sport dans nos vies qu'on se
soit en amateur ou bien évidemment en
compétition
[Musique]
mais je vous le disais dans les titres
aux mureaux aujourd'hui avait lieu un
colloque sur la protection de l'enfance
les départements des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine se sont associés pour
réunir plusieurs dizaines de
professionnels et échanger autour de
cette thématique le reportage d'astrid
bergère un colloque a été organisé aux
mureaux sur les services de protection
de l'enfance
dix mille trois cents enfants et jeunes
majeurs sont suivies par ses services
dans les yvelines et dans les
hauts-de-seine
le budget est conséquent 370 millions
d'euros chaque année mais la politique
menée semble inefficace
pour autant si nous hébergeons ses
enfants si nous les logeons nous ne leur
donnons pas toutes leurs chances pour
pouvoir retrouver une place dans la
société
si l'aide matérielle et financière doit
perdurer les questions liées à la
psychologie au traumatisme de l'enfant
doivent être prises en compte
comment gérer le traumatisme parce
qu'autrement on voit bien que chez
beaucoup on les retrouve un peu plus
loin sont les retrouve dans la rue on
les retrouve souvent au chômage
et d'ailleurs le chômage peut les amener
dans la rue et on a vu à l'occasion des
récents procès des islamistes que un
certain nombre d'entre eux étaient
passés par des structures d'être social
en france donc c'est bien la
démonstration que les traumatismes n'ont
pas été traités parmi les projets la
création d'un institut
interdépartementale du psycho
traumatisme de l'enfant la création de
cet institut psychotraumatiques de
l'enfant est quelque chose de très
important puisque on sait bien que
plutôt on prendra en charge mais
traumatisme de l'enfant mieux on pourra
les soigner et venir en aide et prendre
en charge ces enfants
cet institut se veut donc être un outil
de traitement mais aussi de recherche
100 millions d'euros y seront consacrés
sur dix ans et de cet institut on en
parle avec le docteur jean-marc belle
game bonsoir bonsoir pédo psychiatre
médecin légiste vous êtes le co pilote
de ce projet les hauts-de-seine et les
yvelines ont donc pour ambition est
d'ouvrir un institut interdépartementale
du psycho traumatisme des enfants avec à
des locaux physique au sein du conseil
départemental des yvelines à versailles
déjà quelques éléments de définition
qu'est ce qu'on entend par psycho
traumatisme c'est contre ma tisme
c'est la réaction psychique qu'on l'ait
les personnes les individus les humains
un événement potentiellement
traumatisant c'est à dire suffisamment
important pour venir percuter nos
structures psychiques
avec des conséquences qui peuvent être
immédiates comme le stress aigu ou le
stress d'espacer les épisodes de
dissociation certes les gens ont
l'impression depuis être dans le temps
depuis être dans l'espace de pu être
même et puis progressivement une
pathologie psychique et le stress post
traumatique mais pas que et puis à long
terme des troubles de la personnalité et
des enfants qui vont venir des adultes
qui qui seront en difficulté face à
l'autonomie face à leurs modalités
relationnelle affective sociale
professionnelle et c'est donc en fait à
la fois prévenir le l'événement
traumatisant
c'est à dire la violence faite aux
enfants et à la fois prévenir le passage
à des formes graves et notamment à un
adulte qui aura papables la possibilité
d'être autonome
justement pourquoi c'est important pour
l'enfant c'est à dire que l'âge ne
protège pas des événements traumatiques
ça peut se répercuter vous le dites plus
tard dans la vie
alors là je ne protège pas des
événements traumatiques même plus on est
vulnérable plus non des sujets aux
traumatismes et l'enfant et réputés
vulnérables et notamment dans le huis
clos familial la maltraitance a lieu en
général dans le huis clos familial
et oui effectivement ça peut donner
notamment les éléments de stress post
traumatique que tout le monde connaît
maintenant mais surtout des troubles
pérenne de la personnalité et notamment
des difficultés émotionnelles des
troubles émotionnels des troubles
affectifs voire des troubles
comportementaux et monsieur bédié on a
parlé le risque de passage à la
délinquance j'ai l'habitude de dire que
la délinquance juvénile est un symptôme
jusqu'à preuve du contraire de la
maltraitance et donc de ses de ces
épisodes traumatisants de l'enfance si
on en revient justement à ce projet
pourquoi est il nécessaire on sait que
les départements ont pour vocation
d'aider d'accompagner les jeunes au
travers de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
notamment
il manque aujourd'hui en plus cette
prise en charge
psychologique aussi sur le plan médical
ça manque aujourd'hui
alors le projet est porté à la fois par
les deux départements donc des yvelines
et dieu des hauts-de-seine mais aussi
par le centre hospitalier de versailles
1 qui est donc un portage par trois
institutions
sur le plan sanitaire
il ya il ya des choses qui sont déjà
fait mais effectivement on est on est
plus large que le sanitaire on est dans
le prendre soin de tekken qui veut dire
prendre soin au sens large globalement
de l'enfant est donc à prendre soins
sanitaires mais aussi en prendre soin
éducatif à prendre soin de la santé
mentale psychologique du développement
on est clairement dans le fait qu'on va
essayer de respecter les besoins
fondamentaux des enfants ou de tout
humain qui sont à la fois des besoins de
sécurité d'appartenance à un moment etc
on va pas faire le lepron ici et donc on
s'est rendu compte qu'il n'y avait pas
d'offre sur nos deux départements ou en
tous les cas que l'offre était tout à
fait parcellaire qu'elle n'était pas
coordonnée et que la prise en charge
était pas globale ya des gens qui
prenaient en charge tel ou tel type au
plan éducatif au plan sanitaire ou au
plan psychologique aux plans social et c
est donc ce qu'on voulait c'est à la
fois coordonné et à la fois former les
professionnels parce que beaucoup de
professionnels sont pas formés pour
qu'en fait sept prix de l'institut soit
en fait le lieu d'une prise en charge
locale c'est à dire que l'institut va
favoriser contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait imaginer la prise en charge
locale dans son territoire de vie de
l'enfant va pas se substituer aux
structures mais au contraire les formes
et quand elles sont pas formés les
renforcer si elles en ont besoin et
apporter une expertise tout à fait
particulière parce que vous l'avez vu il
ya à la fois une démarche clinique
mais il ya aussi une démarche recherche
qui est extrêmement novatrice une
recherche dépendante de la clinique
calqué sur les besoins cliniques et une
recherche qui va être tout de suite
utilisé par les cliniciens de quels
qu'ils soient et éducatifs sociaux
scolaires médicaux psychologiques et
c'est donc un lien très fort avec la
recherche d'une recherche qui va nous
permettre d'avoir des techniques de
prise en charge innovante parce qu'on
sait que souvent les enfants sont en
rupture les mineurs sont en rupture
parce que nos prises en charge sont pas
adaptés à eux et à leurs troubles et à
ce que leurs troubles a généré chez eux
dans la dernière minute de cet entretien
on a là on l'a compris les objectifs
prise en charge plus globale plus local
aujourd'hui on en est où concrètement il
ya eu aujourd'hui à l'occasion de ce
colloque aux mureaux la signature d'un
groupement d'intérêt public de la
convention de ce groupement d'intérêt
public pour la création de cet institut
ça veut dire qu on en est au tout début
on est bien avancé dans ce cas on est
bien avancé dans la définition de
l'institut en tous les cas il fallait
effectivement qu'il soit portée par un
groupement d'intérêt public notamment
c'est ce trio d'institutions qui sont le
conseil départemental des yvelines des
hauts-de-seine et le centre hospitalier
versailles et on a déjà réfléchi bien
entendu à la façon dont le le le
l'institut allait fonctionner et cet
apport de moyens va nous permettre de
mettre en place les structures
donc vous l'avez vous l'avez cité au
sein d'un lieu du conseil départemental
des yvelines
les structures et les et les hommes et
les femmes qui vont intervenir dans cet
institut
alors ses débuts 2021 merci d'être venu
en parler sur ce plateau jean marc ben
kemoun pédopsychiatre et copilotes je le
rappelle de ce projet d'institut
interdépartementale du psycho
traumatisme de l'enfant
[Musique]
l'épidémie de kovy 19 qui ne cesse de
progresser à nouveau les derniers
chiffres dans les hôpitaux yvelinois
sont à la hausse on dénombre huit décès
supplémentaires en 48 heures dans les
hôpitaux du département
et depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
584 personnes ont succombé au corona
virus dans les établissements de santé
yvelinois 272 passion était hospitalisé
du coronavirus hier sur le territoire
+10 depuis dimanche enfin 32 personnes
étaient toujours en réanimation soit 7
en plus en 48 heures et face à cette
deuxième vague perceptible partout en
france le président de la république
emmanuel macron doit s'exprimer ce soir
de nouvelles mesures restrictives sont
attendus des couvre-feux ou même des
reconfirme en plus locaux sont évoqués
rappelant d'ailleurs cette période du
confinement qui a duré deux mois au
printemps dernier si la période a permis
à de nombreux français de resserrer les
liens familiaux
pour d'autres elle a été aussi une
source d'angoissé le constat que dresse
plusieurs psychologues ou un médiateurs
familiaux que célia 400 go a pu
rencontrer à voisins le bretonneux
camille d'honorer psychologue depuis une
quinzaine d'années elles rencontrent
chaque jour des patients avec des
problématiques très variés juste après
le confinement
elle a vu une hausse de sa clientèle un
jeune qui peut lui malheureusement
devait signer un contrat de travail
prendre ses vacances au début du
confinement démarrer un travail là rien
eu il s'est retrouvé chez ses parents
pendant tout le confinement
ses parents ont tendance à toucher un
peu à l'alcool très régulièrement on va
dire lui il s'est mis à boire de plus en
plus et puis vraiment le dernier mois du
confinement il exprime un sentiment de
de dépression profonde
vraiment un vide un vide abyssal
aujourd'hui il retravaille
il va un peu mieux mais tout ce qui
s'est passé pendant ce confinement
il a ça a mis en lumière des
problématiques familiales qu'il avait
avant mais de façon tellement forte
qu'il a une angoisse permanente qui
ressent toujours la période de covin
n'est pas fini ce qui angoisse les plus
fragiles d'ailleurs les troubles liés au
confinement peuvent apparaître plusieurs
mois après en fait on voit que les
débuts on va voir beaucoup de monde on
va avoir beaucoup d'effet on va de plus
en plus et notamment à cause aussi des
masques
les enfants souffrent des masques donc
les écrans plus les masques les enfants
au niveau du lien il va y avoir des
problèmes qui ont qui vont arriver mais
ça on va voir les effets dans 6 9 mois
et les effets du confinement se sont
ressentis aussi sur les couples pour
cette médiatrice familiale
il s'agit de leur donner un espace pour
communiquer dans de bonnes conditions
la plupart des couples reconnaissent que
la fragilisation du lien familial n'est
pas exclusivement due au confinement
dans la grande partie des cas ils me
disent c'est pas ça qui a causé
voilà la situation dans laquelle nous
sommes dans le conflit dans lequel nous
sommes
mais ça a été un révélateur voilà
révélateur très fort de deux choses qui
a dépeint comme si on s'était retrouvé
face à face à face à nos difficultés
face à nos problèmes et le télétravail
qui tend à se généraliser ne va pas
faire avancer les choses
certains auront besoin de plusieurs
séances pour atténuer leurs névroses
d'autres au bout seulement de trois
séances auront réglé leur problème
c'est peut-être votre cas 66% des
français avouent regarder leur
smartphone au moment de traverser la rue
selon une étude deloitte un réflexe qui
peut s'avérer dangereux et que souhaite
endiguer la ratp la start-up cap sonic
elles ont mis au point et me une
application qui prévient l'utilisateur
en cas de danger une expérimentation est
en cours à montigny le bretonneux ou
deux passages piétons étaient équipés
justin brasier et la voix de nicolas
kirillovitch et mis un dispositif pour
protéger les piétons pour l'heure sous
forme d'application il permet d'alerter
les utilisateurs qui s'apprête à
traverser au feu rouge
une solution qui s'adresse surtout aux
smoby et smoby c'est un nouveau mot
c'est la contraction de smartphones et
zombies
pourquoi smoby parce qu'on sent les
zombies quand on est sur un téléphone
dans la rue on est tous à un moment
parce qu'on est en train de rechercher
notre itinéraire parce qu'on regarde nos
mails qu'on est pressé et maintenant on
est tellement absorbé par son téléphone
on fait plus attention danger qui nous
entourent notamment quand ils traversent
une application qui utilise la
technologie des ultrasons le programme
envoie une alerte sur le téléphone en
cas d'inattention ou de danger quand
vous avez téléchargé l'application et
que vous activer la fonctionnalité amis
en fait si vous vous apprêtez à
traverser la route alors que le feu est
rouge vous allez recevoir une alerte sur
leur téléphone alors l'air tu es de
plusieurs types
ça peut être une alerte sonore ici on a
choisi le bruit d'un klaxon des voitures
c'est assez surprenant quand vous êtes
sur votre téléphone
une vibration et un message visuel
attention le feu est rouge dans les
yvelines le dispositif a déjà été
implanté à vélizy-villacoublay sa rémy
les chevreuse et mantes la jolie
ici à saint quentin en yvelines de
traversées piétonnes ont été équipés au
croisement de l'avenue du centre et de
l'avenue gustave eiffel un emplacement
stratégique ya un point de passage qui
mène du centre commercial à la gare aux
nombreuses entreprises du secteur du
quartier est également de l'université
de versailles saint quentin qui est
derrière juste à côté donc à toute heure
du jour principalement il ya un flux de
passage en courant continu pour l'heure
encore en expérimentation la
fonctionnalité pourrait par la suite se
retrouver dans des applications telles
que celle de la ratp
whatsapp deezer ou encore spotify
elle a débuté à carrières-sur-seine est
passé par poissy et faisait étape
aujourd'hui au square de la marche à
maurepas la tournée de l'apprentissage
se poursuit dans les yvelines
cette opération lancée par le ministère
du travail a pour objectif de parler de
l'apprentissage aux jeunes les visiteurs
peuvent découvrir les futurs métiers
accessibles via l'apprentissage par le
biais de casques de réalité virtuelle
des vidéos à 360° des démonstrations le
bus fera également arrêt demain au
marché de belleville des mureaux et au
parking de l'agora late show à mantes la
jolie
c'est toujours en ce moment octobre rose
le mois de sensibilisation au cancer du
sein et notamment pour parler de
dépistage on sait que le cancer du sein
peut guérir dans neuf cas sur dix il est
effectuée si le dépistage est effectuée
de manière précoce une marche solidaire
se tenait 5
dernier dans les rues d'aubergenville à
l'initiative de l'association au pluriel
elle a réuni 160 personnes le reportage
de justin brasier pluriel à chausser ses
baskets pour lutter contre le cancer du
sein
une marche rose de 6 km organisée à
aubergenville samedi 10 octobre
objectif sensibiliser et créer un
mouvement solidaire face à la maladie
un sujet qui tient à coeur il s'avère
qu'il ya deux ans j'ai été moi-même
touchées par cette maladie
personnellement et beaucoup de personnes
dans mon entourage familial et amical
et donc c'était vraiment l'occasion
cette année de la mettre en place avant
le départ de la marche
un ruban rose géant a été réalisée avec
les participants
une action symbolique n'a mis en place
ce ruban géant humains ruban rose qui a
été pris en photo pour la symbolique
c'était une petite feuille rose qu'on
devait le mettre au dessus de sa tête
parce que la photo a été prise
en hauteur donc par un drone 160
marcheuses et marcheurs étaient au
rendez vous pour cet événement solidaire
il était présent pour sensibiliser et
soutenir les personnes atteintes du
cancer gelée par expérience dans mon
entourage donc je pense que c'est
important de le faire connaître cette
maladie un peu plus d'en parler surtout
ça fait à d'épicéa j'ai eu le cas aussi
avec la maman donc d'autres personnes
que je connais donc allez vous faire
dépister c'est le principal déjà par
solidarité puis parce que le cancer à
touche toutes les familles dont la
mienne
nous on va bien on a cette chance
mais d'autres ne l'ont pas donc donc on
est là on est là pour ça au total 1100
euros ont pu être récoltés en faveur de
la ligue contre le cancer et sur tb
60,18 ce soir le 7-8 société sera
justement consacrée à la thématique du
cancer du sein mélanie poker et ses
invités parleront du dépistage peut être
plus difficile à réaliser en ce moment
en période de crise sanitaire
c'est un rendez vous annuel sur la scène
nationale du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le théâtre a
organisé la semaine dernière jeudi 8
octobre sa soirée mécénat l'occasion de
faire découvrir à la trentaine de
mécènes présent une représentation une
représentation vécu de deux manières
différentes de manière classique face à
la scène et puis face à un écran avec
des lunettes 3d on écoute l'un des
mécènes du théâtre des propos collectées
par nickel et demi d'euros et nicolas
landry je suis ici ce soir pour soutenir
la fabrique du mécénat donc en
partenariat avec le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
puisque nous sommes mécène depuis
l'année dernière d'un projet qui vise à
apporter la culture auprès des enfants
malades de l'hôpital de bullion dans les
yvelines auprès de rambouillet nous
allons apporter notre notre témoignage
est aussi inciter d'autres mécènes ont
peut-être à s'investir auprès de la
culture et auprès du théâtre de saint
quentin sur le territoire et flinois et
pour refermer ce journal marie
antoinette sous toutes les couleurs à
versailles c'est ce qui est à découvrir
jusqu'à dimanche à l'orangerie du
domaine de madame elisabeth la
photographe tard à soultana propose des
photos mélangé à de l'art visuel dans
l'exposition marie antoinette new look
eléonore sinoquet patrick jacques de
dixmude serions nous revenu au 18e
siècle
tout du moins le temps d'un après midi
dimanche 11 octobre au domaine de madame
elisabeth à versailles une petite troupe
a défilé en costumes d'époque
à l'occasion de l'exposition marie
antoine new look de la photographe
amateur depuis 20 ans taha soultane à
marie-antoinette new look c'est une
rencontre
avec marie antoinette lorsque je
travaillais au château de versailles
j'étais dans l'accueil et la
surveillance et comme je ne lâche
pratiquement pas un appareil photo je
crois que c'est marie antoinette qui
lorsqu'elle m'a vu passer elle a deux se
dire tiens c'est la bonne personne
c'est la personne idéale pour me sortir
du trianon débuté le 7 octobre dernier
l'exposition est un mélange de
photographies et d'un visuel
l'artiste a décliné à 14 reprises la
photo d'un buste de la reine un travail
numérique
en fait mon travail c'est un petit peu
comme c'est le pwm un procédé que la
peinture abstraite de travail partouche
les couleurs se diffuse un petit peu et
ensuite je dois chercher les endroits où
il faut poser telle couleur telle
couleur une exposition pensée pour
étonnés émerveillés ou encore émouvoir
tout un programme à découvrir jusqu'au
18 octobre
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]